then I found a machi
before when car tester michelle austyn
McClair thought of Jaguar she thought of
luxury sedans with a discreet elegance
and an exclusive clientele then this one
came along then done come dare you it's
loud and wild but stylish the Jaguar
f-type R puts out extraordinary
performance encased in an extraordinary
design
[Music]
the stretched hood moves the passenger
compartment farther back curving into a
tightly rounded back with broad rear
fenders
the f-type R looks just as curvaceous
coming and going this all aluminum coupe
a is the sportiest snappiest production
model and jaguars history
[Music]
[Music]
the big cats 5 litre v8 engine puts out
405 kilowatts of power with 680 Newton
meters of torque its top speed is
electronically capped at 300 km/h the
f-type R makes the 0 to 60 sprint and
4.2 seconds
Domon light on this didn't up there
since she doesn't head out to the
racetrack every day Michelle would like
to know if she can turn this predator
into a kitten but the super charging and
direct injection don't make it easy to
tame
Michelle wouldn't say this ballistic
missile has any sense of English
propriety it's loud it's brutal and
brawny
and roars out the back so nobody could
fail to hear it for the handsome 100
7000 euro sticker price in Germany the
coupe a has to command respect the
8-speed quick shift automatic
transmission makes for pickup on the
road and goose pimples on Michelle
[Music]
to get it stopped again just as fast
there's an optional carbon ceramic
matrix braking system as Michelle says
all she has to do is look at the brakes
and they catch the gas pedal responds
almost as fast barely tap it and f-type
R leaps forward no British
understatement here looking almost like
a wardrobe malfunction is the active
rear spoiler it pops up automatically at
speeds exceeding 110 km/h but doesn't
pop back down until the speed drops
below 80
Michelle is very pleased the Jaguar
f-type r's torque vectoring system works
with an electronically active
differential together they optimize
traction and stability rounding curves
and enhance the steering and agility and
germany another six thousand euros gives
this jag all-wheel-drive in little boy
once Michele's turned the engine off the
interior almost makes her forget she's
sitting in a beast all the materials
feel so good and looks so nice but the
nicest part of all is raising and
lowering the vents it almost seems
choreographed all the f-type interiors
are geared to the driver all the
controls are within easy reach the
comfort and joy are the performance
sport seats offering inflatable side
bolstering for extra support of the
upper body during high speed cornering
the premium leather adds a sensual touch
[Music]
michelle is still trying to tame her
Jaguar she'd like to be able to take it
shopping and bring home cases of mineral
water she's amazed that she could
actually fit two inside but more space
in front so this is a car she can use as
a deposit Remagen scoot
about us highlight for books but the
real highlight is upfront under the hood
zorgons she doesn't think she'd ever be
able to tame the Jaguar f-type are
completely at heart it will always be a
wild beasts with brute force there may
be no way to hide it but nobody's likely
to steal it either this Jaguar is heard
as much as seen the sound will turn
heads on every side right from the
moment the engine lets out its first
mighty roar
you